punch the numbers and Eddie was
officially our favorite teacher taking
maths to the masses the educator has
presented to sellout crowds and has
racked up over 38 million views on his
whoo Tube channel I love that mass helps
us understand and wonder at the world
around us in a deeper way than we could
otherwise it's really about taking what
I love and just saying you know what if
we put that on a platform that can
access the world there's no limit to
what we can achieve now the Australian
local hero is sharing his love for the
subject once again with a hands-on
activity book getting kids thinking
about the magical world of maths while
also having a bit of fun and Eddie Wu
joins us live in the studio Heidi or
should I say a rise Lord Wu brush with
royalty recently oh I did so it's the
60th anniversary this year of the Duke
of Edinburgh wars here in Australia and
I remember when I was at school you know
people go on hikes and they would go
bronze silver gold so it was really
wonderful the earl of wessex Prince
Edward he came to Sydney just a little
while ago to award some gold recipients
Prince right yeah I lovely and just a
personable super professional about
getting around to like 300 people who
had to give awards to but also yeah an
incredible mentor he's not getting
credible and you're pretty good yourself
maths of course it's a bit of a tricky
subject but you kind of like to make
your equations relatable so I saw before
on the graphics you the other thing
about apple pie and beef and is it
important to make maths I guess in a way
easier to understand I think one of the
things that makes mathematics so
challenging is that it can be very
abstract what are all these X's and Y's
what do they stand for what do they mean
and so I think you know a provides but
if that was me describing probability of
getting a meal and understanding a
context that connects it to you that's
so important for kids and for adults
yeah and your passion for this knows no
bounds you really have a passion for
taking this to regional Australia as
well why is that for me one of the
things I think is hardest is when you've
got an area that doesn't necessarily
have the access to resources a lot of
these places with drought or with
automation they're not seeing the same
kind of economic benefits as they used
to and so kids in these areas it's no
fault of their own it's not like they're
any less smart than kids in metro areas
but it's so wonderful to be able to take
out two that a message of positivity and
be able to embrace something like
science or mathematics and help them see
they're just as valuable as kids in
other areas help them get excited too
well you've got a new book right this
book is called Eddie was magical math
what can we expect from this one it's a
very practical book last year I released
my first book and it was really aimed at
I'm a high school teacher yeah
adolescents and above and so many people
said to me parents mostly how well does
my kid need to be to be able to read you
look and I'd say older than that and so
it's taken us a year to put together
this it's very practical hands-on
activities that can help kids and also
their parents are embrace mathematics
and see the joy in it yeah right even so
we got involved we did so we we did one
of your activities from the book this is
the most crafts Ellie's done great for
but we made some snow 4s it's brilliant
so quality's why these a good example of
maths okay so a couple of things number
one what I put these into the book about
is symmetries symmetry is when you can
change a shape like spin it around or
flip it over and it ends up looking the
same every snowflake in nature a tiny
microscopic level has this kind of
symmetry that's why you've got this
wonderful geometric mathematical idea
it's been sitting under our nose our
entire lives what I want people to be is
aware and sort of appreciating where
mathematics is around them
great yeah now year 12 students
obviously at the moment this this is
test time right this is some of the most
stressful times of the year for then
what's your advice to kids out there
they're about to sit down and do some of
these exams well they're going to get
lots of pretty typical tips do your
homework revise all that kind of think
those are all great ideas my big secret
it's not really a secret but when I
started becoming a teacher and
explaining maths other people that's
when number one it really started dawn
on me how much I didn't know and I had
to learn and number two I started to
connect the dots
I couldn't just solve a question I could
explain the links between all the steps
to other people that's where I've
deepened my understanding and I
encourage any student preparing for
their final exams say that master
selling I'll explain just a single
problem
do that once rather than 50 simple
problems and that'll really deepen your
understanding okay
I'll quiz you later and you can try out
some of the eighties fun maths
activities in his new book Eddy was
magical maths it's out now